[Music]
I've just been dropped off in the middle
of Antarctica with Mr Beast and six
other Youtubers with the challenge of
surviving the harshest conditions known
to man for 50 hours with nothing but our
sleds and the bags on our back however
not as a cast member I was behind the
camera dealing with the ruthless
climates but while holding all these
cameras and trying to get the best shots
possible in this video I exposed the
truth of what it's like to shoot a Mr
Beast video and if they are actually 100
real in the first place everything that
you won't see in a Mr Beast video all
your hard work I appreciate it
this video is brought to you by artless
but more on them later
um yeah let's go to Antarctica
um yo what like what the [ __ ] uh so what
I really want
[Music]
you perfect Cheers Cheers Cheers
earlier today Mr Beast called me out of
the blue asking if I'd like to join
their Antarctica trip with a brief of
purely capturing god tier shots I packed
way way too much stuff
[Music]
then I'll obviously be taking my iPhone
and this camera that you can see over
there then I traveled for 52 hours which
consisted of two flights one Airport
Hotel
two more flights and that was just to
get to Chile
to wait another five days in isolation
then on the fourth morning at 4 00 am we
got the call let the mission begin how
are you feeling I feel great how are you
feeling
I'm scared what's your prediction on
Surviving the challenge of living out
there well uh surviving five percent
finishing the challenge 100.
playing touchdown the 50-hour time has
started so I immediately ran outside the
plane to get the shot of the boys
arriving and then the plane flying off
this is when the sudden realization
kicked in we were now stuck on a literal
Giant floating Glacier at the
southernmost tip of the world
where the weather is so unpredictable as
we started walking this massive blizzard
just came out of nowhere so he quickly
had a setup Camp which was near
impossible
where are roomied with my good friend
and Lead camera operator for Mr Beast to
read especially getting rough man we
then had to build a wall for protection
from the blizzard yeah these list of
these challenges are real I always
thought like
there could be a possibility there
they're half real
even though Mr Beast could use his Fame
to get away with not doing the manual
labor he built most of that ice wall
himself and then eat we made a little
mixture of stove we're taking this
boiling hot water and pouring it in
these MREs and that's how you eat an
Antarctica
Sports everyone make sure you eat a ton
of food because tomorrow you're going to
burn a lot of energy
come back into my own tent to eat this
I could not eat that I have such a weak
stomach it's gonna be a struggle with
food
it's currently 2 30 a.m and the Sun is
as bright as ever that's because here in
Antarctica the Sun never sits just goes
like this
we are officially 10 hours into the
challenge my water bottle stuff
[Music]
he has a house tour here's the front
door for your shoes and your piss
we're not even lying Antarctica has to
leave nothing behind policy so the
toilet situation works like this grab
pee bottle open pee bottle and
comfortably try not to mess while peeing
in bottles dispose in big container
now to show you how to take care of your
other business walk a thousand feet to
mysterious tent make sure no one is
inside entertained
you use a disposable bag with a special
chemical inside and put in bucket try
not fall over if so get up with haste
tie bag up and dispose sanitize hands
and exit
welcome to Mr Beast video This is my
first experience in a mystery studio and
my last
bro this is just another Tuesday
my hands are stuck like this
are your hands okay no what are you
gonna do now you're gonna shoot I'm
gonna pretend that I've hurt my foot oh
no I'm gonna go in there
I won't tell anybody
[Music]
I'm gonna get some sleep
[ __ ]
these two fingers started to like
experience some really sharp intense
pain
I don't care no you're gonna lose her
finger no we're doing put on your lips
I'm not filming with your exposed hand
in hindsight I really should have
listened to Jimmy
what I've learned about him on the trip
is that no matter how driven he is about
getting the shot he always puts
everyone's Safety First updates on my
finger I got this condition I can't
remember what it's called the guy told
me
put it here
I can't wear my gloves probably when I
for focus when I film I never use
autofocus so focusing with gloves makes
it really really difficult first
breakfast
baked apple porridge
not bad not bad
uh bread freeze this is tough this is
really tough we are currently 20 hours
in getting to know the camera department
and the production team Behind These
incredible and these massive these
ginormous and great videos that Mr Beast
makes along with these co-stars has been
an opportunity I've never been afforded
before and I've learned just so much
then while the boys were sleeping I took
the time to Mission off and capture some
cinematic stuff the weather's crazy it's
like this is perfect moments of
Stillness listen to this
and then within seconds it can just
blizzard
then when I got back I continued to film
with Jimmy calls all the goofy goobers
just being their hilarious selves it's
too cold out here man
we all need to calm down
[Music]
the city is our I'm gonna have a five
hour nap
and then 15 hours left
[Music]
actually not feeling too bad
[Music]
thank you
the main caffeine source of the trip
[Music]
Jimmy then made an announcement that
he's going to climb a mountain that's
never been climbed before just so that
he can name it that again just shows his
sheer dedication to making these viral
videos it's incredible while Mr Beast
Tariq and Nolan climbed a mountain I
went in search of a glacier that had
never been walked on before I'm in the
middle of Antarctica on a glacier that's
not only never been stood on before but
also where the Silence has never been
broken by noise so I thought why not
make a song
C F A B flat g e d
ude
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
back to the video I raced back just in
time to shoot Mr Beast arriving back
from Conquering the mountain which took
him a total of seven hours I don't think
I've ever felt my pinky toe before
what I do now we have four hours
remaining and before we can leave for
the plane we must pack everything up and
we need to make sure there's no P or any
other stuff in the snow okay
we had to pack up super fast in four
hours so that we don't miss the plane on
the 50th hour as much as I love
Antarctica there was absolutely no way I
was gonna miss that plane this is it one
hour left we are about to Trek to the
plane
[Music]
got the last shots of the boys
missioning back
the plane is five to ten minutes out the
boys are waiting right there
I'm gonna shoot it and then we out of
here
I just got back from one of the wildest
experiences of my life definitely
by far just crazy
what's happening with Mr Beast and I
what's brewing here is there something
big is this something that's going to be
happening in the near future but before
I answer that question I just want to
tell you about the sponsor of this video
artless max I put so much time and
energy into attempting to make my edits
as Innovative as possible and let me
tell you if there was a shop a One-Stop
shop where you could actually purchase
creativity it would be artless Max they
provide hundreds of thousands of Premium
songs sound effects footage templates
and plugins together with editing
software to provide creators with a full
solution for Content creation oddness
Max really it just makes the whole
post-process that much easier and it's
really affordable you get Max Pro which
is everything you need to create amazing
content all in one plan including easy
to use editing software for 39.99 per
month then Max social which is all the
features of Max Pro tailored
specifically for Content media creators
and this goes for 29.99 per month and
then there's Max teams which is all the
features of Max Pro for your whole team
starting at 29.99 per month and what's
awesome if you click on the link in the
top of my description you get two months
for free on any annual subscription
click it below and then yes to answer
the question Jimmy Mr Beast and I and
his team we are about to join forces on
an amazing new Venture it's incredible
it's an incredible opportunity and I
can't wait to tell you more about it
which will actually be in the next
couple of days so turn on your
notifications so that you don't miss
that video subscribe if you're not
subscribed already and you're still
hanging around let me know your thoughts
in the comments below of this video and
yeah other than that don't forget you're
awesome and I'll see you next week
[Music]